morning reject nation it's Greg Albee
here ah John is me the real rejects
technical difficulties continue 2018
last night I was getting ready to go to
bed so I could wake up at 6:00 in the
morning to cover this trailer you got to
understand something John and I we have
laptops both stop working but we have a
computer tower that we do everything off
of now that completely broke down last
night my brother but till 5:00 in the
morning trying to help us get this fixed
and right now we're borrowing his laptop
I passed out at 5:30 and sure enough the
venom trailer dropped a little bit later
yeah you just couldn't be awake it's
gonna be awake anymore but here we are
Eddie Brock became the venomous so
things are later than usual now it's
because we don't have our awesome Tower
that we've been building the channel off
of for the past couple years so off the
video negative that's how you do every
good video okay
yes
takes place for right after spider-man 3
everyone's got the egg
[Music]
maybe it's a breakup a death
[Music]
whatever it is used to be y'see
[Music]
there is
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
there's more bad teas that's not a bad
teaser trailer it's it's got a cool tone
to it
yeah very gripping very dark I like Tom
Hardy's voice yeah he's like Ryan
Gosling New York this is from the guy
who did like Zombieland in Gangster
Squad so I was expecting a slightly more
fun toad even though it's a venom movie
but I guess for a venom movie you would
want a darker more serious tone I'll
admit guys while this was a nice teaser
trailer it's kind of the same way I feel
about solo right okay cool teaser
trailers I like what we're getting so
far knowing what this movie is and that
this is just a Sony Pictures property
and no spider-man in here I'm still like
I don't know how this was gonna be I
still have no idea how this movie's
gonna be I mean it's Tom Hardy gonna
live up to Topher Grace is like I say
they just don't we just don't know I
know in the comics that sometimes venom
could be somewhat of a hero and yeah
seriously yeah we can work but his
storyline is still linked to spider-man
so this isn't really giving us a story
line but there's images here that I did
like when Tom Hart is like waking up
it's doing that cool kind of framework
[ __ ] they're doing oh yeah he's like
having a like seizure thing and yeah the
MRI machine I mean this could be the
Eddie Brock that we wanted for awhile
that's the one that's one thing I think
that it seems cool about it without
spider-man being here I think that at
least we could get a performance by the
great Tom Hardy that give you worthy of
an Eddie Brock yeah part of me feels
like no matter how this stacks up as a
venom movie you know Tom Hardy will
probably be pretty good at Michelle
Williams is always good too and like the
tone is cool like it's dark and serious
and stuff the way it's kind of shot and
everything is reminding me more of like
amazing spider-man
Sony's stamp I mean as a tease it's cool
that we don't actually get to see
anything beyond just a bit of the
symbiotic goo in a vial setting up our
hero to I really hope that this movie
mentions Peter Parker and we just never
see him yeah like like just they have
arrived okay with that Parker yeah it's
like a lot of the other teases we've
seen it's like this looks perhaps like a
better movie than I thought it was gonna
be yeah I still have no idea how well
what I'm hoping this does because the
symbiont
is a race you know last time we saw this
symbiote it was spider true oh yeah so
I'm hoping that this one is just really
needs to be a strong course correction
and a strong reintroduction there who
venom is and what the symbiote is and
what the symbiont race I think is like
there is a whole world you can do I
think you can do this without having
spider-man in here but right now I'm not
getting my hopes too high right now
like other if it's a cool tease but it's
like I'm intrigued but I'm not sold yet
yeah Tom happy Tom Hardy's a big saving
grace yeah yeah just because you know
that no matter how the movie will take
seeing actual venom for me cuz I know
that was a point of contention for many
people when spider-man 3 came out just
not only the way they handled the
character of Eddie Brock yeah changing
him do this like scrawny wiry topher guy
but also just the look of him when he's
venom in full form you know I know some
people had big problems with that so
part of that too will come down to how
they orchestrate that for this movie
that's what trailer number 2 is gonna
have to sell me I can respect the fact
that you just see the symbiote you don't
see venom in here for first trailer for
a first rate I can respect that and I
don't prefer that I would have liked at
least a little look yeah little
something you know or a hint of how
these jaws are I'm skeptical about this
one but all I know
I'm gonna watch it anyway yeah war
there's no guarantee that this is gonna
work
Sony doesn't really have a baseline
anymore other than scrambling to get it
right yeah you sure this action scenes
that don't have venom they're booked
whatever I don't know look like the
government might want the symbiote for
themselves of course they of course they
do you need a good good guy subscriber
the real reason good that notification
valve
guys before I start getting too
skeptical they do you think they're
gonna tease the seven symbiotes and
never make the sequel where we see them
comment below check us out on patreon
people ya know working computer it's
been a long two months